Travel is a little bit perhaps like
music or looking at art on the wall.
You kind of have to have somebody teach
you how to do it a little bit. Yeah,
it's like the fight
game, Yo, you know, you,
somebody could sit with you and and
get really bored with technical boxing.
It might be the best you've ever seen
and it's not a slug fest or a Braun.
You have to explain,
well see some jazz,
some jazz bitches,
brew Conor Mcgregor's bitches brew
arguably one of the smell several.
It's all over the place and let's say,
and some is very contained
like the disc jockeys voice.
Yeah, yeah. There's some
people very mechanized.
The jazz thing is a really good analogy
because you either into jazz are you not
into jazz and I've never,
I liked a lichen is background music,
but I have a good friend,
my friend Alonzo Boden is a jazz efficient
natto and he like host jazz tours and
stuff and he's a stand up comic.
So he'll do like comedy on these
things and he just loves it.
I mean he like lives for it. Well, I,
she look on your face just because
nobody taught you how to taste beer.
Beer works in three parts and like
it says in the Pickwick papers,
you don't taste it with a ship.
Wait. Tastes, yeah. Gotta go up.
You've got a quaff. You got something.
And when you describe, well,
there's the finish to the taste
of a Cuban cigar. They go,
you mean when it's finished
in the APP? No, the finish.
Okay. Somebody explained
these things to me. All right.
What's the difference between Scotch
whiskey and Tennessee Bourbon? Well,
there's an e in the word,
Bourbon whiskey. There's an e in,
there is no EDD in the war. In
whiskey for Scotch. Okay. That simple,
short of starts it jazz music.
Somebody explains it to you
in very simple, digestible,
not lofty neck tie terms.
Okay?
You begin to understand a little bit
of what's going on. How do you get,
how do you explain it to them? Okay.
How would you explain jazz? I'm gonna,
I'll really tighten up for
you. Um, excuse me. Wow.
At least I've got my
health. Go for me. Huh? Um,
we'll do it in the Beatles style.
Here's the best way to go for somebody
new and interested the McCartney note and
that Lennon knew. Okay. The Mccartney
note is always kind of happy.
I've actually bumped into Sir Paul over
at Henson Studios and he's really happy.
Okay. And here's another, we'll go. Yeah.
Nah, Nah, Nah, Nah, Nah, Nah.
Here. How pretty that sounds. That
sounds pretty. I'll do it again. Yep.
Bada Bada Ba Lennon.
He's the salt and the caramel
baby. He's got, there's a darkness.
There's an edge. There's a shadow.
Listen to the last three notes.
Ah,
Donna.
Ah.
Dropoff.
And there's a little darkness.
It wasn't those last three notes
is where you'd get that little,
just a little bit of pepper
in the chocolate. Yo. Nada.
MMM MM
hmm. And it's a little wistful, is a
little melancholy and eat life like that.
And when you put them together,
it doesn't sound like they do.
But if I could, I'd sing both parts
and it goes together and you go, wow.
Bittersweet. Mm. Like my fucking career.
Like my last three rules.
There we go.
So you kind of have to listen to jazz.
Like you would taste one ish,
k the best for this felonious
monk, you know, same thing.
The right hand is Paul left his
job and he's working these days.
You can't tell is it happy? The Shad,
right? I Dunno. How was dinner last night?
Same,
but yet it is a indicative of that's
what's around you because snatches dappy
that's Disney snatches sad.
You know, think of something,
somebody who's always
tuning his guitar to sad.
There are some folks who,
Leonard Cohen in his past as well,
that sounded more like Bowie,
but I know what you mean.